my first confirmation that maybe i had
when it takes to be entrepreneur
with steph picking me out of hundreds of
soldiers
and giving me a prize and giving me this
poster
i hope it doesn't mess up your filming
but that's perfect
this poster is on my um wall
it's signed by steph and the artist who
made it
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with loamy tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford
this entrepreneur and investor literally
did it all
meet ellie wardman managing partner at
pico venture partners
ellie is co-founder and partner at pico
venture partners an early stage venture
capital fund headquartered in jerusalem
his investments include vroom spot io
gloat charge after and auto lead star
prior to pico wortman was a general
partner at benchmark capital from 2006
to 2012.
prior to that he worked for three years
at with jvp
where he led early-stage media
technology and enterprise software
investments
ellie wardman thank you for joining me
on 20 minute leaders i am so incredibly
happy that you're here
hey michael good to meet you uh it was
great to discover that i worked with
your sister
probably a decade ago which is pretty
amazing unbelievable
unbelievable so you have good taste you
chose the people
correctly which i think is a is just a
slight indication for the incredible
journey that you've had
uh i think what can sum it up um along
with
the incredible impact that you've had
both in the jerusalem ecosystem
founding the first unicorn of jerusalem
we talked a little bit about zionism and
impact
and your thoughts but but also things
like pico kids
these initiatives that you're saying
taking some time out of of you know the
busy
life to understand that you know we have
an opportunity to make an impact i
gained so much inspiration from that and
i'm so excited to hear
about your mindset and your thinking
behind
impact but just uh briefly before we
started you mentioned
something really amazing yesterday when
you when you
watched the vroom super bowl commercial
i'd love for you to repeat it because it
was just so awesome
so i'm actually sitting at the dinner
table with my 15 year old
liam and we're listening to spotify
and the vichy song came on hey brother
and i realized that that was the
soundtrack
for super bowl commercial i had worked
on with another startup i had called
enjoy about eight years ago and i said
it's pretty amazing two super bowl ads
you know one guy two different startups
um that must be a pretty like serious
accomplishment i've had two startups
with
30 seconds in the super bowl so i'm
going to add that to my list of things
and hopefully i impressed my 15 year old
son in the process
i i i'm sure that he was very much very
very much impressed
uh but along with all the other
incredible things that you've done
part of them were you know co-founding
pico venture partners which is an
incredible
fund based out of israel you also were
the g
general partner at benchmark you know a
world recognized
venture fund where you also worked with
my sister
and two really incredible things are
that you are the owner of a world
winning winemaker i have to learn more
about that
but you also used to spend a day a week
working from amman jordan
which is also incredible so i have to
dive deep into these two things first
michael you've done a lot of research so
i uh the secret to my success is being
ideologically driven
and i have met too many ideological
passions but one of them has always been
that through technology and through
innovation
israel will build bridges to peace
around the world and
whether it's connecting israelis and
americans or israelis and jordanians
that
that this desire to use innovation to
use creativity
to create a better world the better
reality more
prosperous kind of economies is
something that's always driven me
so in the late 90s people seem to forget
we were very optimistic
that peace in the middle east was upon
us
um and i believed together with some
partners from saudi arabia of all
places wow that we could build the
largest
uh i.t services company in the middle
east i was one of the entrepreneurs
uh the chairman we had the jordanian ceo
we had lebanese partners egyptian
partners
saudi arabian investors it almost sounds
like a fairy tale
and to top it all off i commuted from
jerusalem
to amman jordan by car across a bridge
uh 90 minutes kind of door-to-door
and you know really believed that while
we were building a business
and creating jobs that also we were
doing the most important thing which was
bringing people together
breaking down barriers and this is to me
the magic of being entrepreneur that we
can take
you know business ideas and business
enterprise but also achieve
additional goals that we have to make
the world a better place so that's
jordan
um baslomo and wine one of my
favorite passion projects so i can knew
that you said
you know benchmark i went to silicon
valley
uh i commuted from israel to palo alto
where i believe you live part-time
actually my little park every six to
eight weeks it was a
very long flight especially before the
direct flight to san francisco
so i used to spend the weekends i go for
10 days and next to
silicon valley is napa valley
and a good friend of mine a good friend
of mine ari earl
was making wine at the time at one of
the top boutique wineries in napa and
every weekend we would visit
10 12 wineries and i realized that
there's a huge connection between high
tech and innovation
and wine and in both cases the desire to
build
long-lasting things and the amount that
one has to go into tending the vines
and really nurturing you know great
outcomes and great products
and when arya was moving back to israel
i had stumbled upon the place called
bachelor mo
where israel had started it was the
first aliyah
settlement from 1889 and i
said you know this is amazing if we want
to understand how israel got to where
this today
we have to start uh back then in the
late 19th century and what did they do
back then they grew grapes
uh for the uh for the carmel winery in
zircon
and um i said all right let's bring the
latest technology the latest
methodologies and
build a great winery in israel
but also preserve the history express
our love for the land
through our organic environmental
farming practices
engage in social impact we actually set
up an educational program
called greg for kids who are
um great kids there's nothing wrong with
them they just don't like to go to
school i don't know if you've ever met
anybody like that
i was like that so they work in
agriculture every morning they do their
academic studies in the afternoon
and the entire workforce of bachelor
are these young high school students we
pay them a fair wage it offsets
their their fees for schools the
boarding school
so it's an economically sufficient
enterprise
but we also make great wine and it is my
pride and passion
and i love getting together with
entrepreneurs over wine so michael
before you go back to california please
come visit us in bachelor mo for wine
tasting
off the record off camera we'll just
have a lot of fun
i'm already already so excited that we
did this i i just love this
thank you very much ellie you're
starting in jerusalem
you're creating your first company the
first unicorn
that came out of jerusalem you're in
jerusalem now you
you travel ironically right almost as if
in a fairytale movie you're
all over a bridge jerusalem to jordan
once a week in the late 90s as you're
as you're working way ahead of your time
and
and hopefully not too far ahead
hopefully soon but tell me a little bit
about you know jerusalem and a little
bit about where you are because
you know to if i talk to a lot of my
friends in in stanford
i would ask him hey where is you know
startup nation well it's tel aviv
but but it's shifting a little bit and
it's not it's not instead
and it's along with we have jerusalem as
this wonderful wonderful hub
and that again you were ahead of your
time with the first unicorn tell me a
little bit about your connection to
jerusalem and why
you're passionate about about being
there
so sometimes if i'm speaking to a public
audience i'll i'll ask everybody have
you read the book startup nation and
all the hands go up if it's a tech tour
and then i ask everybody
have you do you remember the chapter on
jerusalem and michael do you remember
the chapter on jerusalem
i can't say that i do you know why
because there isn't one and uh it is the
unwritten chapter of jerusalem is my
belief
about jerusalem and actually the hidden
secret of the success of startup nation
starts in jerusalem there is something
about this city
the complexity of the city the uh the
history the perspective of what it takes
to build big things
uh when you look you know at the old
city jerusalem and you can see with your
own life 3 000
years of history you say hey
what is my calling what is my layer of
history that i am going to write
i think that complexity leads to
creativity that just to survive every
day in the city
we have to flex our creative muscles so
kind of drive and perspective of what it
takes to build big things
complexity combined with creativity
diversity all of the different sounds
that
and smells that uh bring our hearts to
life
whether it's the jerusalem kitchen which
has become famous in tel aviv
through all of our chefs i think all of
these things have
driven jerusalem mites people from the
city
to become the leaders of the high-tech
industry and let me surprise you with
some of the greatest
and biggest outcomes of israel so
everyone knows about
mobileye because it's in jerusalem i
think you know that the ceo of waze grew
up in jerusalem
that the ceo of cyberark
the ceo of uh melanox
of checkpoint the four of the seven
founders of iron source
the list goes on and on and on i'm
leaving myself off the list
but the amount of over-the-top
large accomplishments that have been
built
by jerusalem mites people who to this
day if you say
where are you from even if they've lived
in tel aviv or stanford for 30 years
they say a knee you'll shout me i am a
jerusalemite
it is something in the identity that has
both
depth and vision and creativity and the
desire to go out and do big things i
think there's some magic
in this city that just pushes us to go
further
and i'm a believer in the city and i'm a
believer in the people the city
and pico kids which you asked me about
is really an expression
of my desire to make sure that the next
generation is getting
a fantastic 21st century education
with a very strong sense of identity who
are we
where am i from what is my past what is
my job in the present
and how am i going to define the future
and all of this
is something which i find magical about
the city
and i understand you know tel aviv is a
much
cooler much more fun city to hang out in
matter of fact pico has an office in tel
aviv
but the harpy of uh of the entire
high-tech
innovative ecosystem i believe comes
back to jerusalem
and i just invested in a company called
afugata
and i was very touched i don't know if
if the entrepreneur you know knew about
my passion it was just symbolic he said
ellie
i'd like to bring the investors to
jerusalem
to the hotel we'll make a small blessing
we'll break bread together and we will
be on our way to building something
great this idea
that you know everyone loves the city
whether you're from here or not there's
something magical that that just
connects the whole world to the city so
i'm i'm fortunate to live here
i'm fortunate to have grown up here to
have been one of the builders
of the high tech ecosystem here are some
very successful
startups some less successful startups
we've had failures here too it's part of
the program
um but you know i believe that there's
something here that keeps on
providing a specific energy
to the israeli startup ecosystem
incredible and of course i casually left
out that you spent three years with the
jerusalem venture partners
even before that along with all the
other incredible things but you know
ellie i have to say
you know i love machine learning and i
love patterns and i'm seeing
an incredibly clear pattern here which
is about
this idea of leaving a legacy and you
know
with that is an impact that creates that
legacy and we're talking about
impact on a nation on on a startup
nation we're talking about impact on
on society on on kids whether they're
with the winery or whether it's with
pico kids
and we're seeing an impact that we
haven't even discussed it which is the
incredible impact you're making on the
tech ecosystem worldwide
whether it's through the public
companies through an investor as an
entrepreneur
and so all around just a phenomenal
mindset
and one thing that he told me before we
started this is that it all
comes down to this ideology of making an
impact and being driven
through that impact talk to me a little
bit about how you go about and
and exercise that as well with founders
that you mean because
not because you know a lot of founders
are young a lot of them like myself are
inexperienced and i'm
excited to be an inexperienced founder
sooner rather than later and
how how do you translate this you know
very mature mindset through a lot of
experience
to young founders as they go on
hopefully responsibly
building tools that you know the world
is going to
to embrace so
you know i'm very much a
[Music]
values-driven person and and i believe
in values-based leadership
um and you know we all have our own
frameworks for for me the framework
was uh and is zionism
and what that means in terms of building
a great society here values driven
society
but that you need prosperity to get
there you need to do good
um and you know part of the ecosystem
that we've built to pico is very much
putting on a uh putting kind of on our
front door
pico is about social impact it's about
creating a better future
and also about creating you know great
startup outcomes and embracing
entrepreneurs i believe i might be wrong
that entrepreneurs are drawn to us
because of our values
and that there's lots of money out there
and there's lots of experienced people
out there but our commitment
to building you know a better society
to build creating more jobs creating
positive
positive companies who can leave a
positive mark on the world
it's part of what we represent and i
think it's it's important it's it's our
abc's it's what's really important to us
but this idea that values come first and
you know i'm very fortunate when i was a
soldier in the army
and i had no idea what entrepreneur was
or what high tech was
i had the good fortune of going to an
education week up north
that was sponsored by one of israel's
greatest entrepreneurs that many young
people
may not even know his name steph
fahrenheimer and he um
until recently was probably one of the
most successful israeli entrepreneurs
ever he's in his
80s now his company was purchased by
warren buffett by berkshire hath
hathaway
i think for about eight billion dollars
back with eight billion dollars meant
something
and um and he had set up an education
program
for israeli soldiers to learn about the
different
populations in the north of israel about
his vision
of how we could all co-exist to live
together how we could build green
industry high-tech industry but he also
had a vision that
that it was part of the continuum of
zionism that that zionism started
with settling the land building homes
agriculture working the land caring for
the land
and then israel as everyone knows lives
in a tough neighborhood
and phase two was the ability to defend
ourselves
and the green branches of this tree
which represented his ideology
um we're you know we're we're our
defense establishment we're the idf
but the fruits uh he at the time he's
industrialists he had kind of uh
you know the wheels uh of industry
and in this prophecy almost he talks
about the phase three of zionism being
high-tech which will lead to prosperity
and peace in the middle east
he wrote that 1984. wow i think there
was a high-tech industry here in 1984.
i encountered him in the early 90s
and you know i have lived by his
philosophy
right i have lived that my work as a
high-tech entrepreneur
creating jobs continuing in the
footsteps of the pioneers
bringing economic prosperity to this
land
as an enabler to fundamentally create
prosperity uh and peace in our region
is something which our entire industry
is taking a part of whether
everyone is aware of it or not i have
had the good fortune of having that
ideology
laid out for me in three minutes by
stuff for a timer
now you then ask me but why did you lay
it out for me
because in the last day of this uh half
day
of this education week they ran an
entrepreneurship competition
i didn't know what entrepreneurship was
i definitely didn't know what a startup
was
but he had challenged all of us uh
soldiers
to come up with an idea for a product
and to pitch it
and you know my first confirmation that
maybe i had what it takes to be
entrepreneur
was steph picking me out of hundreds of
soldiers
and giving me a prize and giving me this
poster i hope it doesn't mess up your
filming
but that's perfect this poster is on my
wall it's signed by steph and the artist
who made it
uh a very dear colleague of mine
uh sasha balanchi
heard the story which i just shared with
you and said she has to track down this
poster and she tracked down the artist
a few months before he passed away
tracked down steph
got them both to sign it and presented
it to me for my birthday
there's not a more meaningful birthday
gift i've ever received it's just
amazing
because i live by the ideals represented
there
ellie this is more than phenomenal i am
more than inspired both by you know your
your ideology but
the way that you came to those values
and i think that i'm
i'm looking both at the city of
jerusalem a little bit
different after this conversation i
already have wheels in my mind about
about what's next but just in terms of
daily life and how do i interact with
people and and how do i think critically
about the the impact that i want to make
hopefully the positive impact and and
having the privilege
of working on meaningful things that
could make an impact on a lot of other
people
ellie thank you so so much for for
coming on the show i am
so incredibly thankful for your time
before we leave though i do have to ask
the most important question the most
difficult one
which is three words you would use to
describe yourself
you know you 20 minutes ago you prepared
me you said this is coming and i didn't
prepare but i
gave you 10 seconds mission
um drive and
uh a lot of heart mission drive and a
lot of heart ali
thank you so so much i'm gonna see you
at the winery and i'll see you in
jerusalem
and i'm taking up on that offer thank
you for everything this is great
thank you michael this is fantastic
thank you so much for doing this